their lives are flashing in front of
their eyes
[Applause]
there's a lot of guys who can dump and
who can jump and do things but you know
I look for more than just being able to
executed that's just half of it that's
just a piece of it can you just make it
look easy that's what I'm talking next
level the evolution know that don't open
in the mind of all of these athletes
this guy's taking pieces of what people
done paying homage dr. J made the
seventies here this is something you
don't see every day he was showing how
far he can fly the one thing I admired
about this dunk was that ya guys can go
up high but how far can you jump and the
free throw line was a pretty solid
anymore
[Applause]
now Dominique was it was a I considered
you know an angry dog what I look for is
full extension full extension is a real
winner
anything else is paper mills when you
just blowing those sheets of paper off
the table or something you see the the
power coming through and you know this
is one of the dunks that I personally
could do but not like that that's the
carry on the subject the first question
I asked him as a teammate it's like did
you pee so this is from some distance so
you have to have trust and I want to say
he told me he practiced it a couple of
times and I think you don't know where
the rim is if you jump a little left or
a little right into mr. rims hey you're
hitting the ground he's thinking of this
that's impressive man I'm sitting here
thinking in between dunks like what can
I do what can I do no that's not good
enough
come on with that I didn't want to
another I just wanted the arena stylist
I want to show height around so I'll try
to get the ball fully extended high as I
can't above the rim before coming back
at the same time I want to make sure I'm
hiding if I don't fall off I took a risk
made for a good competition
this here is next level he took in front
feet the line showing distance obviously
hang time ability suppressive man hands
down I mean it's just next-level in the
evolution of the dunk and what's being
done this guy's taking pieces of what
former dunkers have done and put in
their twist on just what do you think
what else could you do look
guys have the god-given ability to just
complain I'm gonna do what I do